make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with the
conclusion of Scott Snyder's Justice
League and there's actually a character
that's going to appear that I want to
draw your attention to I think it'll
give us some indication as to what's
going on here because if I'm a betting
man here I think this is how DCE and
Marvel's crossover event basically
starts now what kind of get through that
you know what kind of kind of talk about
that as we go through this but what this
does is it picks up in the the immediate
aftermath of the last video did we did
buy the last issue issue number 38 where
Martian Manhunter had basically returned
now in and of himself Martian Manhunter
wasn't really powerful enough to turn
the tide of the battle right and we
expected that I mean Martian Manhunter
is a really really popular character a
lot of people really really liked him
but he himself is not capable of doing
that right because they're facing off
against Perpetua the creator of the
multiverse and so Martian Manhunter is
just like a stronger version of Superman
it's really what he is right at the end
of the day you compared him pound for
pound he's basically Superman except he
has telepathy he can shape-shift and
he's afraid of fire right that's
basically yet between the you know the
differ between the two characters now we
know he's stronger than Superman because
of the old grant war singe ala comics
but at the end of the day he's not
powerful enough to turn the tide of
battle on his own what makes the Martian
Manhunter important is that this war
this this conflict against Perpetua
right the idea of doom versus Hope which
is really what this whole thing has been
about in terms of the the power of doom
overtaking the power of Hope or vice
versa is that it's a battle over the
souls of men right that's that's really
what it is that's one of these things
were this isn't really a conflict that
Justice League can win through sheer
force it's a conflict of what side of
people going to choose right if people
decide to choose the side of the Justice
League to choose the side of justice and
to walk away from doom then ultimately
perpetual will fall whereas of people
side with justice of course the just in
your Justice League inand the heroes
will essentially win and the Martian
Manhunter pleads his case to humanity
right and basically says it's one of
these things where we are all greater
than the sum of our parts as individuals
we're not necessarily strong what we're
capable we can do things but what makes
us powerful what makes all of you guys
powerful as a fact that working as a
cohesive unit you can all achieve great
things it's really one of these things
were you know perpetual kind of gets the
upper hand on it momentarily and it's
one of the things worthy Schoology kind
of you know reaches out to humanity at
the same time and says like none and
enough doom is what matters doom is what
will win right like you guys cannot
possibly hope to defeat me and even
tries to use lex luthor as a pawn right
and says like kelvin like tell them the
truth
you know and at the end of the day lex
luthor's like you know i'm sorry and
ultimately faith and justice we're
winning out in this particular kind of
mental conflict and so you have these
this kind of you know debate this kind
of discussion going back and forth not
really debate with the martian manhunter
continuing to kind of plead his case to
people we are all capable of great
things we as superheroes we fight
because you're people worth fighting for
right like you are our heroes you know
we look at you guys and we see you as
our heroes you know you guys see us as
heroes but it's the opposite way it's
the other way around and so where he
pleases case he continues on over and
over and over again at the end of the
day doom wins that basically humanity
turns its back on heroes and it's one of
these interesting things right because
leaving my own opinions out of this this
really is kind of a critique on society
right as it literally is a a social
critique that humanity in you know chose
individuality and it chose doom over the
superheroes now the reality of this is
this choice was long in coming it was
something that that ultimately would
have taken place and the reason why is
because when your various members of
humanity and you look at superheroes yes
superheroes do good things that's true
no what you see is conflict you see
heroes fighting villains you see cities
getting destroyed you see collateral
damage
you see people kind of asking the
question why do we need heroes at all
but the real big thing here is that
people are basically reaching down and
looking to their most base desires
they're not really looking at what they
can achieve
they're looking at what they are in the
here and now and that's one of the
things that's kind of intriguing because
it's easy to paint humanity as as
villains right it's easy to look at this
story and say okay the true villains of
this story are people it's the average
Joe right it's the average individual
out there who if given the choice will
always choose the worst version of
themselves and people do that because
it's easy to do it's much much easier to
just give up than it is to keep trying
is easy to say that but the reality is
that when it comes to humanity that the
overriding factor here the overriding
thing is fear and that's ultimately what
was being fed on by Perpetua as
ultimately what was really being being
fed on by her and the forces of doom is
the fear of people that people were
afraid but the funny thing about this is
that when perpetuo really kind of chimes
in what she says is that this is all
going exactly the way that it was
supposed to that everything that's
transpired is transpired exactly because
she wanted it to she wanted the Martian
Manhunter to plead his case to humanity
she
all of this to take place everything
that's happened has happened according
to her design and she knew that
ultimately humanity was going to choose
the side of doom and the reason why she
makes this argument it seems like the
reason why she makes this argument is
because all of this exists partially
because of Perpetual raipur eventual had
her version of the multiverse that
existed and it took the monitor and the
anti-monitor in the forger of worlds to
team up and basically imprison her
inside the source wall and then recreate
the multiverse as it exists right now
but all the inhabitants of the
multiverse all the humans that exist out
there are basically branched off in some
former fashion of humans or Martians
right every single entity that exists
out there is branched off of either
humans or Martians because at one point
in time in the the multiverse that
Perpetua created is that you kind of had
apex predators right humans and Martians
were a singular entity and so when when
this was kind of wiped away when they
ultimately split it was wiped away and
then all new life was created in this
multiverse the apex predators were
basically split right so every iteration
of a Martian you see is based off the
original Martians and every single human
that you see is of course based off
humans as they were split as they were
previously apex predators and so what
this means if this kind of confuses you
a little bit what this basically means
is that in the eyes of Perpetual or at
least in the eyes of Eden you know the
way it exists now that if humans and
Martians were originally a singular
being that when they split humans were
basically the weaker side right and
Martians were the more powerful side and
so what this meant is that humanity as a
race is inherently weak and the reason
why that matters is because it shows us
why it is humanity chose its base
Airlines in the first place because when
confronted by fear what do people do
people panic they usually give in to it
right that's the social critique coming
into play the idea that when bad things
happen people just want to wait until it
goes away you know really crazy
political environments people are just
like well I'll just wait until things
get better right it's just I'll stick my
head in the sand and hopefully when I
stick my head back up things will be
okay it's the nature of people right
it's a nature of human being so usually
kind of take the easy way out the lazy
way out and did not really confront
their own ended with individual fears on
a regular basis and so when given the
option to either confront their fear and
to push back and see what happens or to
give up humanity chose to give up and
it's not just humans that do that right
as every single race across the cosmos
that's done that and that's the exact
point that were petrol makes you never
had a chance to win because what you're
asking
humanity is too much you're asking
humanity to be brave and that's
something the humanities just not really
capable of doing and so what is up
happening if she basically cleanses all
the superheroes of the earth but like
they're all basically gone you know
seemingly White's out all of the earth
superheroes takes all the various
superheroes that we saw from the
different timelines and sends them back
to their own individual timelines and so
as a result of that it's it's really
kind of left to believe the idea that
the Justice League has been eradicated
from all of existence only for us to
kind of see these sort of green you know
particles more or less coalescing and in
the rebirth of the Martian Manhunter and
when the Martian Manhunter arrives on
the moon completely clad in black he
reaches out with his telepathy to try to
communicate with earth but he can't
write he can't talk to earth anybody
he's really just kind of an isolation
and then he's met by the other members
of the Justice League and they're like
we don't really know exactly what's
going on but they cannot hear us the
indication seems to be that they've
basically been without their powers the
only person with that being the cases of
course Hawkgirl because she has physical
wings but Superman doesn't really seem
to be able to fly Green Lantern Jon
Stewart doesn't really have its ring
anymore you know it seems like none of
them really have their powers or
abilities Superman actually tries to fly
and just lands back down on the surface
of the Moon right so he doesn't really
have his powers anymore and it's one of
these things where Jon Jones kind of
internalizes that and says I saw all
this coming I knew this was going to
happen I knew we were going to lose only
for the group to be met with the arrival
of the quintessence now the quintessence
is in a lot of ways a stand-in for the
sky fathers from Marvel Comics right in
Marvel Comics you've got the sky father
as a council of godheads whatever you
want to call them but it's like Odin
Zeus and all the various earthly cosmic
entities or I guess you know godly
entities that exists out there in DC
this is kind of a larger you know in
terms of the role they play right like
the Phantom Stranger is not a God people
pray to write Shazam is not really a God
that people pray to you my father isn't
a God they pray to you or anything like
that but Hara is right you know she's a
God as the people pray to you so it's
really more of just really powerful
entity so it's not a direct it's not a
not a lateral comparison but it's
comparable but one of the things that I
want you to kind of notice here is that
you have the wizard Shazam and the
wizard Shazam does not look like the new
52 version of his character he looks
totally different look at the classic
version that kind of begs the question
if the quintessence is is universal
meaning that every universe has its own
version of the quintessence or Pierce -
then why does Shazam appear differently
here the difference and this is where
things get a little murky is highfather
for example is a multiversal character
right in all the most
verse there's only one high father
that's why things are kind of murky for
DC because they're multiversal and or in
and Universal organizational structure
is not like Marvel's is right mama
nothing is a lot more clean-cut and a
lot more organized and structured DC's
is just all over the damn place so like
we have no real clue who don't know what
the Phantom Stranger is this literally
he lives up to his namesake he's just
like dis Phantom Stranger that no one
really knows anything about maybe he's
the presence maybe he's not we don't
really know it's just the Phantom
Stranger and like he's really powerful
and you can do some stuff the Phantom
Stranger explained that's basically what
that is right and so because of that the
quintessence basically reveals to the
Justice League that the intention of
Perpetua was to actually wipe them all
out it was to destroy them and remove
them but what they've done is
essentially pluck them out of reality
right so technically they're in the
universe but they're out of phase with
everything else right so if you were an
astronaut looking at the moon you
wouldn't really see them right now right
because they're kind of out of phase
with you oh they're not really in
reality it just looks like they are and
the reason why the quintessence did this
is because there's kind of this hidden
truth across the multiverse that nobody
seems to be aware of and nobody seems to
know about right this truth of the
multiverse that is yet to be revealed to
everyone and because that the Justice
League are in a position to where they
can go find that hidden truth and reveal
it to everybody we don't know exactly
what it'll be but we kind of get these
small little things here and there the
character of Leviathan the events of
Doomsday Clock one of the funny things
about Doomsday Clock is it doesn't
really look like we're giving a
definitive answer
when Doomsday Clock takes place in
relation to this the fact that we're
shown off from Doomsday Clock seems to
show that like it's already happened but
like we don't really know if it's in the
same universe or not that's the
confusion behind all this we don't
really know how all this kind of ties
together but with regards to the wizard
Shazam and looking at him I would argue
that this is only takes place in a
different reality like that's my that's
my knee-jerk reaction is essentially
Scott Snyder's run takes place in a
different universe I don't know right
we're not really given definitive answer
we're left to believe it's in the main
DC Universe right I mean there's really
been nothing to indicate that it's not
in the main DC Universe but essentially
a kind of doors open up right and the
kind of statements made by the spectre
you guys can enter into this space and
you can pursue this hidden truth but
understand if you find the answer to it
but it'll change everything right it'll
completely alter and change everything
now what you end up having is the
Justice League racing into this kind of
doorway and we kind of have to wait and
see what happens next in a Greg Capullo
and Skye Snyder's metal but
perception here this is kind of my my
thought process here we know that Marvel
and DC are going across over we know
that perpetual was sent by basically the
judge of the worlds right the cosmic
judges more or less to create you know
the the cosmos to create a multiverse
and then all the universes that exist
within that multiverse that means there
are multiple multiverses out there right
because one one of the things that was
established here is that Perpetua was
just one of many individuals who were
sent out there into this massive chasm
this massive void of whatever this space
was Endon was told to create multiverses
right so she made her multiverse other
beings made their multiverses and
Perpetua seem to be the only one who
wanted to use the the individual she
created inner multiverse to destroy the
cosmic judges my argument here my
thought process here is the one above
all in Marvel Comics it's kind of an
equal to Perpetua right like the one
above all was sent by the cosmic judges
to create the multiverse and so it's
there now that's kind of how it oversees
everything I mean that's kind of my
thought process reconciling that with
the knowledge of the one above all and
how its role functions within the
greater Marvel landscape is gonna be
kind of tough to do because one above
all is so ambiguous right to this day
including Jim starlings infinity finale
the one above all I think has made 18 or
19 appearances in Marvel Comics if that
it's been referenced more times but not
not even not even a tree or 19 I think
it's in in some form of fashion it's
made 18 or 19 appearances in terms of
actually showing up is showing up like
three times right that's that's the only
the only time I'm aware of there was a
time of the Fantastic Four when it
appeared to the Fantastic Four
themselves and look like Jack Kirby the
second time when it appeared to
spider-man and then there was a third
time when it told Adam warlock in
infinity finale that it could be the New
Living Tribunal and then it made Adam
warlock and the New Living Tribunal
those are the only three times I'm aware
of it actually showing up right so the
one above all is ambiguous as hell and
what better way to kind of basically
establish this secret truth this hidden
truth is that there are a slew of
multiverses out there and the Marvel
multiverse is one of them then to
basically say that what you have here is
the one above all creating its
multiverse around the same time that you
were created in and basically having
like all these different giant
multiverse concepts crossing over with
each other I don't know when I'm
grasping at straws here folks I don't
really have any definitive answers I'm
just kind of spitballing and theorizing
as best I can but it's a cool idea right
it's a cool concept but either way it's
an interesting end right because what we
do is we're gonna jump over or at least
when when this ends you go into rubber
band
run as far as I'm aware it's not going
to pick up from this right as far as I'm
aware this whole thing right here is
going to pick up with like metal from
Scott Snyder and and Greg Capullo I
don't know what Robert VIN Diddy's run
is gonna look like right I'm kind of
curious myself but with that being said
guys forgive me in this video to an end
if you are new here to come it's
explained to make sure you guys with the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and we'll catch you
all later peace okay I want to give a
shout out to Kyle be David Joseph Ben
John h aj matt in Jeff our John H lean
and mean which is an awesome name Jason
see Austin s Austin a Joey M Steven Z
Austin be Adam K and Genesis 9:6 team
you remember guys you could send me
messages and I'll run off whatever your
message is at the end of the video so
long it is nothing crazy but if you want
to put a message in there send me an
email Rob at Robert Jefferson calm and
if you're one of these people who get
shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]